[Musica]
io sono questo strumento
manca ancora qualcosa perché io possa
farlo ma arriviamo tra un attimo ci sono
dei musicologi che dicono che la prima
volta in tempi preistorici quando un
uomo ha scagliato la prima freccia è
atteso un arco ha inventato l'arpa che è
marco musicale ecco questo strumento
ovviamente lancia suoni non lancia
frecce suoni che possono commuovere
nella storia abbiamo orfeo che mitiga
gli animali
davide che mitiga lavano i modelli uomo
e sono eccezioni dell'arte ma tutt'oggi
lo strumento in pratica conserva questa
sua anima primitiva ma cosa succederebbe
se noi invece volessimo cambiare la sua
immagine che è molto standardizzata
perché tutti abbiamo un'immagine
dell'arpa essendo così così unita la
storia dell'uomo
adesso citando le cose particolari la
prima è che muoviamo la mente cambiavano
mostro la nostra immagine e questo è
sempre interessante è la seconda cosa
invece quella di lavorare sul suono e
quindi spostare un po più in là il suono
che voi avete in mente o che avete
sempre sentito dello strumento
ed è quello che sono qui a fare oggi
mostrare cosa succederebbe se si
uniscono delle cose antiche e moderne e
quali sono le differenze e sul suono è
bello lavorare perché la materia di cui
siamo fatti anche credo noi la
vibrazione e l'universo il tutto e
quindi il musicista una grande
responsabilità amareggiare questa cosa è
il primo brano che vi suono infatti è
proprio su questo si intitola a tempio
del suono è un brano di roberto
cacciapaglia lui e lavora molto su
questa accezione magica della sul potere
del suono
cercherò di farlo anche io per la mia
visione di questo brano e quindi vi
invita ad entrare nel tempio del suono
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie
sempre per what if
c'è anche un altro brano è un motivo un
po diverso da quello di prima nel senso
che qui si parla di un brano molto
famoso del novecento adagio for strings
di samuel barber è un brano cake vinsi
incluso in tutte le best of di musica
classica e qualche anno fa però un dj
olandese che non dica famosi al mondo si
chiama dj chiesto mi ha fatto una
versione pop e così un brano di musica
classica per archi è diventato uno dei
box ha votato proprio come uno dei brani
dance più belle di sempre
ecco io ho pensato di farne una versione
per arpa che mi sembra uno strumento
molto dance come potete vedere
[Musica]
[Applauso]